we think that if we could just get a
hold of that that job where we couldn't
get fired or the the financial system
that just can't crash then everything
would be fine but in fact there's
nothing as dangerous as perfect safety
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Megan McArdle
she's a Bloomberg view columnist and the
author of the excellent new book the
upside of down
why failing well is the key to success
Megan thanks for talking to us thanks
for having what inspired you to write a
book about failing well well you know
what the first thing they always tell
writers is write what you know and since
I have failed a lot I thought this is an
area where I wouldn't actually claim
some genuine expertise okay so but of
course you're talking about failing well
what's the what's a good failure what's
a bad feeling okay so a bad failure is
first of all it's a failure where you
don't learn anything where you let it
crush you and you don't move on you just
keep trying to do the same old thing
that didn't work the first time right
failure is Nature's Way of saying stop
that doesn't work and so the key to good
failure is first of all recognizing that
you've felt and that's sounds dumb but
you'd be shocked at how many people just
keep refusing to admit that things are
going wrong even when it's fairly
obvious so this is kind of like an
Anthony Weiner situation well that's one
yes except but I mean everything from
you look at plane crashes you look at GM
you look at bad relationships or even
from the whole gamut you see the same
thing over and over again which is
denial is not just a river in Egypt and
people just cling to this idea that
everything's okay
even when it's obvious to everyone else
from the outside that it's not second
thing is to like
fairly low cost failure now it isn't the
failure shouldn't hurt it should because
again if it didn't hurt we wouldn't stop
but it needs to hurt in a specific way
which is it should encourage you to move
on and not be catastrophic and then the
third thing is moving on is how did
having recognized that you failed having
identified the lessons that you can how
do you then let go of the past and move
forward you right at one point that the
opposite of failure is not safety it's
nothing what do you mean by that well if
you think about it right a lot of a lot
of people right now as
they're looking for that guarantee
they're looking for a sure thing and we
think that if we could just get a hold
of that that job where we couldn't get
fired or the the financial system that
just can't crash then everything would
be fine but in fact there's nothing as
dangerous as perfect safety it means
that you're first of all it means that
you're not innovating and in today's
economy that's incredibly risky is to be
the guy who has settled into doing the
same thing for 20 years and is still
doing it but the second thing is that
when you think you've found a sure thing
you're not prepared for something to go
wrong and you you can say in the movies
that failure is not an option but
failure is always an option and so you
look at the financial crisis a perfect
example right homeowners thought that
they had a sure thing everyone thought
they had a sure thing and it collapsed
catastrophic ly well you also write at a
certain point and this is interesting
because I mean a lot of the book is
about policy issues it's about business
but it's also you know you bring it down
to an individual level through anecdotes
and whatnot but you talk about kind of
the way that schools teach or our
culture kind of teaches a very very very
bad very false lesson which that is that
success and work mostly depends on
natural talent explain that a bit well
if you think about how especially bright
kids go through school right is that
everyone wants to you learn early that
success is just about being brilliant
right you sit down and you do it and
it's perfect the first time you do it
maybe you rewrite a draft and then and
you know you can try to tell kids that
talent doesn't matter but that's
obviously a lie right you can look
around a Grammar School classroom and
know who finds math easy and who doesn't
the problem is that those kids then get
the message that work is a that being
smart is about finding succeeding is
about finding work easy right the
smartest kid in the class is the person
just who finds it the easiest and then
that's reinforced by the way we teach so
how do you learn English right you don't
sit down and read Tom Sawyer detective
which is a very bad book that Mark Twain
wrote later it's not as menaced I'm
sorry I brought but it's getting a yes
he wrote a series of not very good books
later in life because he was desperate
and bankrupt and needed the money
and you don't read any of those books
and you don't read the drafts and you
know one of the stories I tell the book
is I was at a seminar with 12 English
professors and me and we're discussing
Moby Dick and he is this chapter on the
rules for determining whether you're
allowed to hunt a whale or where there's
someone else's and at the end of the
book is a fast-fish which means that you
can you can hunt it or that you can't
hunt it or a loose fish which is one
that's fair game the antis is and what
are you dear reader but a fast-fish or
and the loose fish - and everyone's
sitting around for like an hour so what
is it what did he mean by this and
finally at the end I said I'm just gonna
throw this out here but maybe he just
got to the end of the chapter and it
sounded good just like you would have
thought that I had said like hey guys
after this is over what if we just went
out and killed some old ladies and the
fact is that this is how actual writers
experienced it right sometimes you just
get to the end and but the way we
perceive it after it's written is it's
it came out of his mind fully formed
exactly what he intended and it was
super brilliant and how dare you
question these super brilliant people
that's not how they perceive themselves
and that's not how they worked they had
a lot of false starts there were a lot
of junk better junk than I raved by but
and it's true of science is true of the
way that we teach all of these topics is
we're not showing how these guys failed
and failed and failed until they finally
within a kind of broad-based libertarian
movement I mean it's interesting because
you know there's a real privilege of
work ethic and of trihard try harder but
then there's also this growing idea that
well you know certain people have it and
some people don't and you really can't I
mean this is in large way the message of
much of Charles Murray's work but other
people who say well you know what the
cake is baked when you come in you know
when you enter the world so is that a
mixed message within not just
libertarianism but a lot of you know a
lot of how we teach a lot of how we talk
about stuff that's really not about work
it's about whether you're anointed with
the right genes and the right
environment up through age five well I
would put it this way talent exists
right it would be stupid to say that it
doesn't you can look at different kids
and see that they have different levels
of ability at different things on the
other hand you know my mother grew up in
a town where the state school for the
mentally [ __ ] was and there was a
guy there who could wax cars better than
anyone ever seen anyone's ever seen this
is an Cuomo joke
hahaha I know sadly yeah but the fact is
that like talent comes in different
forms and not all talents are exactly
the talents that make you a good
magazine writer for example I would also
say this is you can write this book and
I tried really hard to avoid this of
just saying look at all these great
smart successful people who failed you
can do it too right I can't be Thomas
Edison but on the other hand I'm better
as a writer which I failed into then as
a management consultant which is what I
thought I was going to do and that it's
not about saying that anything is
possible because that's not true but
better is possible is it possible that
we're entering an age where a kind of
dominant metaphor is the iterative
process of software releases saying at
version 11.10 cetera kind of repeated
efforts that get you closer to better or
to good I actually think that Silicon
Valley has this does have this metaphor
fail faster right you try something and
if it doesn't work you kill it and then
if it does work you improve it and I
actually think that that's it's really
good that that's become a much more
dominant metaphor in our culture for how
success happens but it's important to
say that that is always how success has
worked in all industries and in American
society and in fact what we've always
been really good at is letting people
tries encouraging people to try stuff
even stuff that's a little crazy and
then if they don't succeed saying well
hey I really admire you for trying and
that's not true in all cultures and it's
been a tremendous strength of America
that we do admire people who try things
and we pick them up afterwards and say
okay that was great go try again well
that raises a question about kind of
societal learning curves but because I
mean obviously this is about individuals
and small groups but then on a larger on
a larger level do certain societies fail
better and and learn how to succeed
better as a result of that and others
not so well and it can you give us a
yeah I mean I think you you you look at
cultures that have become where their
institutions have become stagnant that's
often a result of shifts and the culture
of themselves so you look at Mandarin
China
as an example that I've talked about a
lot is that you know they ended up
setting things up so that entry into the
bureaucracy was done by this one exam
heavy on Confucian sayings and that if
you could pass that hurdle you would be
super successful right and it would be
eventually you go back to your province
and you would be rich and you would be
good for your family and so forth and
here's the thing is that you then so
we've created this giant pass/fail test
it's it's a way of first of all
instituting a phenomenal amount of
conformity resisting change and so forth
and then it broke I mean you can argue
that the Communist revolution in some
ways was just the fracturing of a system
that it becomes so interlocked and so
and so yes cultures absolutely how they
treat failure it does change over time
and it doesn't matter a lot in terms of
how successful they're able to do you
talk about a concept called blame
storming and particularly in the context
of the financial crisis explained
brainstorming and then let's talk a
little bit about how that played out in
2008 well blame storming is just like
brand storming where we all get together
in a group except this time we're trying
to figure out who the villain is who has
done us wrong and find the scapegoat for
whatever just happened I think you see I
mean you see that after any major crisis
right you see that I did there's an
there's a particular attempt to search
for everybody has the villain right I
mean this is part of the problem is that
you're not only just looking for blame
but everybody has a different sense of
who it is and that everything proceeds
from one single cause and exactly is
that you look it to me when I look at
the financial crisis I see lots of
people none of whom are any or I should
say very few of whom are greedy or and
stupider than the average person but who
in a kind of bad situation in the market
where they're all getting a bad signal
for the market about housing prices and
they all make a bunch of bad decisions
because of that but most people don't
see that they see greedy homeowners or
greedy banksters or evil republican-led
regulators or whatever it is they see
some person who did this rather than
looking at a system that unfortunately
can occasionally go wrong because
systems fail just like people do and I
think it's it's bad in two ways I mean
the first is you can settle on someone
who
not exactly innocent because I think
everyone had some level of greed and not
being perfectly responsible certainly
isn't more guilty than many other people
and then you ruin that person's life but
the other thing is the thing you don't
fix the problem right we're all focused
if the great comforting thing about
Blaine's storming is that it gives you a
cause that's really easy to remove for
it a person you can just okay fire that
person and put them in jail whatever a
system is hard to fix and so you focus
on something that is easy but not
actually gonna fix the problem very well
instead of these giant systemic problems
that are a lot harder to do you think in
the case of the financial crisis and
obviously there have been a lot of you
know a lot of legislative and policy
decisions that have been made in the
wake of it that we don't even know what
they really are for years I mean forget
the Iraq war it's gonna take longer to
figure out what dodd-frank is much less
how it impacts things is this an example
where we failed well or are we still
failing what's that even realizing I
would say with dodd-frank there were
some things that we did that are right I
mean one thing that you look at is
fractional reserve banking systems which
is a modern banking system as we all
know it they tend to have crises and so
what does one thing the dodd-frank did
with it was smart would say look if you
want to be in these markets you need
more capital you just like because for
the same reason
that having 5% down on your house is
riskier than having 25% down so that was
that was basically a smart regulation we
did things like that that are designed
to enhance transparency or to give
regulators the better and people
individuals just better ability to see
what's inside these banks on the other
hand we also did a lot of things it had
nothing to do with any of this
like interchange fees you know we
decided that we didn't like how much
visa was charging retailers and we the
those sorts of things they're bad in two
ways I mean first of all they just they
lard up the bill with and all of the
legislative fighting then that ends up
getting focused on this thing that
doesn't matter but also then they suck
up regulator time right if you're gonna
have bank regulators you want them
focused on basic things like our banks
are not going to fail and wipe out our
own savings not really tangential things
like is visa charging retailers slightly
too much to use every time you swipe a
credit card well we will leave it there
the book is the upside of down
by failing well is the key to success
it's written by Megan McArdle who's a
Bloomberg view columnist you can see her
work at Bloomberg view on a daily basis
Megan thanks for talking to us thanks
for having for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie